well what meditation is the because one
week is the well when we actually
experience meditation when we're not
trying to do it it's the awakening to
consciousness itself so specific so very
simple definition is that most the time
our awareness is focused upon particular
objects that arise in consciousness
whether they may be thoughts objects
other people and our ideas about them so
99% of 99.9999 almost all the time our
attention is focused on objects that are
rising consciousness so the experience
of meditation is when our awareness is
is released from from identification
with any object and begins to focus on
consciousness itself so when when
awareness focus of the focus is on his
own ground which is consciousness that's
what meditation is
you